First, let's take a minute to look at the component life cycle.
Components are produced by external developers.
Hence, instead of the normal breakdown between development time and
runtime, there are really three phases to consider.
Design time, deployment time and runtime.
At design time, components are specified and built.
During deployment, binaries are configured and
deployed into target execution environment.
At runtime, components are instat, instantiated and executed.
As we shall see, major differences exist between
component technologies depending on when composition takes place and
whether a repository for the components exists.